they just have a hose they can't wind it
and so they need some way the white
banner they need two guys to separate it
and one guy to hose it down I speak a
fully good open tell us about 15 then I
started boxing then it never got bullied
but I wasn't that good at boxing but I
love being in the gym you know I mean so
I was around all the fighters all the
time but I would be the guy in the gym
talking [ __ ] to everybody and I would
have that was my game when I was
sparring with guys it was a guy in my
gym you couldn't hit Willie just
couldn't hit him you know those guys you
throw the punch you know they're the
right there but you throw the punch and
they move half an inch so that they're
not in the more I've seen them before I
hate them guys so I would throw a punch
he would be I'm like [ __ ] so I would
step in and clinch and then I would tell
him she like get one off on it but that
was it and that was the only time when I
throw elbows on him is [ __ ] I'm like
forget that was my only way of getting
it shots at that point I loved them but
there was like guys that were real
fighters in the gym and I was just a guy
learning how to box and so I was like
all right well I clearly have some sort
of talent with making people laugh here
and I was deejaying and I love DJ and I
still DJ but comedy just kind of fell in
my lap it's just what I did you know
Lennox and I were amateurs at the same
time yeah and it's funny because I
remember when he was when he went
sparred with you and 80 84 8 up in the
Catskills yeah when he's getting you
ready for the Empire State Games or was
at the Olympics one of the other big
yeah Wow dude that's pretty cool you
were sparring with Lennox back then yeah
Lennox told me he goes I've met that kid
he goes they never told me about that
kid when I got there because it goes I
met him and he was so nice Mike was just
so nice and friendly and like hey thanks
for coming up he was like oh man this
kids great it's something riggidy goes
the [ __ ] was that
because this tornado came at me yeah
what as a DJ did you ever throw out
jokes were you working we're no in a
comedy in between when I use when I used
to make mixtapes in the early 90s I
would take cuz used to vinyl back then
so I used to take a George Carlin record
and start with like a George Carlin joke
and then mix a song and after it I love
that yes so I think one of them was like
anybody gonna have bad breath Marg but
you could knock a buzzard off a [ __ ]
wagon and then I would start the song
yeah just little just little Clips like
that and I would use Richard Pryor
records or whatever I was just just a
little clip and then drop the music in
that was Mike my signature and then I
and then after I ran out of comedy
records to use I would use a Capella's
and then mix a beat in underneath and
stuff like that that's pretty good I
still make my mixtapes I still make them
I make my maybe three a year now I'm
gonna hear one of those yeah it's only
old schools if you want old school like
a rapper of all time all time would be
biggie nice but I'm big L I like them
C's emcees like guys that could really
spit yeah and have you heard Eminem's
new album oh my god that [ __ ] is
ridiculous fire oh my god yeah he really
[ __ ] goes in yeah and it's dope like
he takes the flow that the kids use now
and he just uses it against them yeah he
does it like them but better than them
like everything it's you know means like
you know he says I do you have any idea
how much I hate this choppy flow but you
be copying the Obama but pop and then
just keeps rapping like that the whole
time but you're like holy [ __ ] he's
really going in on these kids and he
just makes fun of him you know that
Gucci gang [ __ ] yeah it starts coming
too so he's talking about like somebody
told me she'd update his flow he's like
alright here we go
Pootie Tang chicken wing Charlemagne
anything it just keeps making with these
ridiculous things like just to show you
how [ __ ] stupid what they're doing is
it's good that's awesome well there's a
whole thing if you ever listen to the
Joe Budden podcast
him and he goes in on Joe Budden - oh
really oh yeah he he said the only the
closest thing you had to having hits is
smacking [ __ ]
yeah well it was just interesting on
that point of old school versus these
new guys well I mean I get it like like
it everything's got to change yeah yeah
and the new stuff is not for us old guys
I mean that's just not the way it's
designed I mean music is even when we
were kids the stuff was designed for
people our age at that time and now we
grew up with it so it's all our memories
right but every now and then one of
these kids might say something that
makes you go okay you can do it yeah you
know yeah it's you know for us it's rare
it's kind of like our parents would
complain about our music and and their
parents would complain about their music
you know and people complained about
Elvis when he came out you know nay hey
yeah you know no I know I know that's
why I looked at you when I said let me
tell you funny story about Chuck Zito
please Chuck and I are very where we
like brothers
so Chuck Chuck Chuck and I have a house
in Vegas together I like to say Chuck
and I have a house in Vegas together
Chuck Chuck stays at my house in Vegas
quite absolutely and right
matter of fact tonight he'll be there
and he'll call me sometimes like bye-bye
I went is the best houseguest you've
ever had in your entire life one time it
goes and notice there was a leak in your
backyard so he he showed me the pipe
smells like [ __ ] that's all my stuff he
cut the pipe fixed it show me was brand
new my water bill went down to $50 from
250 a month oh wow that's incredible
right and then goes hey Bob I noticed
there was the wall in the back was
separating so I resented it have you
ever had somebody say they've reached he
goes I didn't have anything to stir the
cement with so I used my hands to stir
the cement and use his hands to slap the
[ __ ] cement on the wall they hurt me
for a week after that man it was overall
not normal like you know hey I changed
the lightbulb for you like really
[ __ ] detail things and then here's
the best part he goes hey I hope you
don't mind I decorated a little bit
inside the house to put up some artwork
some paintings I go oh cool I walk in
there's his Elvis thing I go okay that's
Chuck I get it then there's this Steve
Reeves poster I got it that's you know
and then I walk in and there's these
[ __ ] awful like fruit bowl paintings
painting of a fruit bowl I can tell I
can tell what he put it he put two of
them in the [ __ ] laundry room
smaller than the room way right now you
needed some color apparently in his
dining room there was a there was a hole
in there with a hook I said I got
something up there but the wall is all
mirror he's - it's like it's another
painting I'm like a fruit hello where'd
you get all these fruit bowls from ah
they were frayed yeah from any from the
rest I'm gonna say they look like old
Italian stuff like you would see
something your [ __ ] grandmother's
house ha ha ha you got a problem that's
[ __ ] funny you got any good art Mike
no way do you want a fruit bowl painting
oh I got a connection I know what guy no
way
hey my dad just did that painting for
you of you and Frank Bruno you got that
nice when you spanked Frank Bruno you
spanked him twice didn't you like Frank
Frank that's a good guy yeah but I don't
you know it's funny is I was in England
in 93 94 when when Lennox but Frank
Bruno I was doing shows or something
that was 95 wasn't much been later
anyway when I was there I was there I
was at a pub watching Lennox fight Frank
Bruno and they're both British and this
is how you knew that white people loved
Frank Bruno like they viewed him as one
of their own and they looked at Lennox
like an outsider
there's no [ __ ] in the middle of that
fight I heard a white guy behind me go
come on Frankie hit the black bastard
Frank's darker than [ __ ] Lennox oh
good so tell me what did your family say
we have to get them out of Mumbai we're
heading it with my dad's like we must
leave this is not going to end well
we're reborn in India now is born in
Toronto okay that's uh but would you
ever go back yeah I dig it you've been
there before yeah I love it
I'll tell you go with me you'll dig it
actually
they cover you Mike Tyson there's
nothing I can say that you were gonna
see what had a good time Orphanage right
Wow raises all right it's the biggest
cattle in Asia oh I shot my series in
there yeah in that in that it was called
Dharavi slum yeah and I ate food in the
slum at night when they open them and
like that no like you mother guys think
I got sick like you couldn't I was
pissing up my ass for three weeks look
like my my look like my ass had
allergies just running all day and my
[ __ ] could sniff it would have
everyone who goes to India says they
have that experience you didn't get sick
no it's easy to avoid getting sick but
like I'm you know as an Indian kid you
like my egos like man there's nothing
good here gonna make me sick yeah and
then you realize oh yeah I know if you
all the cows in the street oh yeah yeah
the cows in the back oh yeah you got to
watch my you got to watch my old act now
you're gonna really dig it now that
you've seen know yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
slap the [ __ ] out your hand oh yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah
don't leave me steal a purse I thought
grown to grown ones in like three babies
falling I'm in the middle of the street
downtown right do people bother you at
all yeah it's crazy yeah because
everybody knows you are there absolutely
and they don't even speak English they
calling your name that's pretty cool did
you go to - I would imagine you had a
tour guide so that you know too many
people oh yeah it's a little warm
what was the tempo you're there one
hundred and over and all humidity oh oh
yeah brutal killing you didn't went with
you I mean my wife and he's mean how
would the keiki like yeah did you like
the food did you eat in the hotels yeah
we know
bomb-ass food though right yeah that's
what we in any country we go to this way
we can go to the Train I mean the Indian
store you know
Indian food man never let you down I
gotta get my mom to cook for you nicely
the one with number one spice curry good
for you man all those Ayurvedic herbs
yeah yeah good for you also make you fat
oh [ __ ] really
oh yeah cuz they put a lot of oil and
butter like pure butter oh yeah yeah
it's good and you get the butter chicken
or whatever it's over Russell would you
say you had a traditional Indian family
upbringing 100% no really not in the
house my dad's name is Eric Reginald
Peters oh really mom is Maureen
Christina you know so and I hung around
black kids from the age of four that's
all I knew with black people
yeah that's why I was like well this is
what I know my kids weren't nice I mean
there was no Indian people around me so
I was like wow well this is what I know
so that's why I'm so comfortable when
I'm around black people isn't my that's
my first choice and then Chuck is my
second haha thank you buddy
thank you very much hey Mike who was
that one fighter I'm always asking
people I he kind of looked like Darren
was at Darren Van Horn maybe who had
like a twitch and when he was fighting
he would almost throw his hand over his
shoulder do you know I'm talking about
man quite a few fighters didn't nobody
had like a twitch he was like and he was
a white kid and he was I was like and
right before I throw a punch would he
just throw it over his shoulder what was
that interesting
I think it might have been Darren Van
Horn if I'm not mistaken but it was like
a white guy like that in like the early
90s late 80s wasn't Pete no put chucks
the best cuz hey boy come on I got we're
going to the fight again we get to the
fight or no I'll go hey I got tickets
and I Chuck come with me so Chuck and I
go to fight
goes these are the [ __ ] tickets they
gave you that's like seven three goes
[ __ ] [ __ ] they don't [ __ ] like
you do there I go
I'll check what am I gonna complain they
gave me free tickets not [ __ ] that we're
moving up and and we end up we're
practically end up in the guy's corner
yeah hey Baba hold the spit bucket he
needs some give me the vest let me put
it over his eyes we did move it right
here we've done that every time I go to
chuck we move up to a better seat nobody
says anything nobody's gonna say it's so
funny when you walk with Chuck and Chuck
is like you know he's a street celebrity
so yeah I see cops like hello mr. Zito
I'm like that was a cop talking oh my
god you aren't you I would expect the
Kospi like a [ __ ] shot you know but
they're like be mad respectful that's
awesome
well I mean he's definitely earned it I
think your mood really changes when you
get punched in the face really like
you're going you're feeling great and
then you get hit like what I do to this
guy what happened what happened yeah
that was that was one of my first Golden
Gloves fight I fought this stocky black
kid I mean the kid was really buffed and
everything he came out he came out like
a bull Jack style Henry I'm strong hit
me an overhand right on top of the
temple I backed up and I said to myself
what the [ __ ] am I doing here
that was the first time I got hit in the
ring it was the same [ __ ] but I want
them knocking about the second round so
but I think that second is what tough
[ __ ] am I doing it the first time I got
hit in the ring I was sparring with guys
that I knew and I was like [ __ ] I do to
you what do you mad at you and you know
the thing is you don't get a headache
till the next day all right so it sucks
it's like your pain is on layaway yeah
the next day I'm like well no then you
go to same time you wake up then you get
the headache yeah well um I could have
been driving this thing I like this yeah
man it's driving this [ __ ] I like this
hey I got questions for you Michael you
are a Brooklyn cat yes
do you remember okay do you remember a
cat named
gangster guy grab when you were growing
up rap he used to run with the real 50
cent
well I knew those guys back then Darrell
and fifty in those guys yeah so you must
have known rap rap just got out from
doing 32 years
well now the thing man
the raps my people so he's gonna be in
town in a couple of weeks staying at the
crib that's crazy some friends waiting
to come out there he did 25 it's insane
right yeah yeah they don't know how they
didn't get crazy in there yeah yeah you
gotta have some PTSD coming out of there
yeah me wrapped it for 14 years in the
hole 14 years in the hole imagine these
guys I wasn't behaving yeah didn't play
well with others
you guys do 30 40 years they come out
their cell phones exist I mean yeah you
got a really adjust man oh oh he's no
longer stretch chuck up height just did
six years there was nothing nothing it
was something buddy I couldn't do six
hours I'll tell you that
holy [ __ ] and that's just processing and
I started four months in Japanese prison
oh yeah the Japanese when I'm gonna be
reading that in your book yeah what was
that I mean I was locked down 23 hours a
day I was in myself oh really that was
probably third of this room they keep
you away from the pop you know
population because I was American and I
was locked down 23 hours a day you know
the little cell a little 6 by 8-foot
cell so why do they keep you away I
guess because I was very resident I was
I was there waiting together extradited
and then what have influence over people
yeah but people say that I was little
guys a little man they had some big sumo
looking guys what he call it as guards
yeah oh really
oh yeah and they weren't just a little
five four three guys hey guys what if
you decide that you want to become a
sumo wrestler and you go and get that
size and find out you're no good at it
man I mean some of those guys are 400
pounds oh absolutely yeah they're
considered gods over them yeah boy store
boys the whole it but there but oh
really
God really that's why they invented
those Japanese doll boys just have a
hose so they can't wait their bath so
they need some way the white there for
them they need two guys to separate it
and one guy to hose it down it's all
boys and sumo wrestling right so you
can't have a dirty ass with that thong
stole boys that's your mo and some dudes
just dying for that job sure they're
like ain't that some [ __ ] sure that's a
shitty job pun intended
yeah that's all good then they can't
squat your arms ain't long enough that's
why they probably invented the Japanese
toilet for that reason alone yeah yeah
you know what's that the toilet this is
the water in your it's the best thing in
the world
dude oh my god oh the day yeah I use a
bidet or the Japanese tours heated seats
yeah yeah you can adjust it now you feel
yeah the water temperature the pressure
the angle if it's not hitting your hoop
directly and then I mean it's it's all
good I haven't used let me taste some
let me just ask you this are you or you
use it when you go to the house yeah
doesn't my Giver what are you a wiper
from a wiper now son you can't do that
[Laughter]
let me tell you B now you a wiper killem
ask you I mean what else am I supposed
to do let me ask you this let me ask you
this if you guys don't have the day
listen to me if you got [ __ ] like a tiny
piece of [ __ ] on your finger right would
you wipe it off would you wash your
hands
you'd wash your hands so when you get a
chunk of [ __ ] fall out your ass like why
do you think it's a good idea to paint
your ass with all that [ __ ] cuz all you
do is you keep wiping ass until the
toilet paper looks clean but it ain't
clean all you did was spread the [ __ ] so
thin it ain't showing up no more when we
are one of the only countries in the
world who does that I know that's where
you got a wat me tell you hey I'm with
it liberation of a clean soul that can
do that is amazing that capability my
[ __ ] so clean at all times that when
I when I'm looking at my underarms like
I have to smell it and still smells like
the detergent I'm like I'm good I'm not
bragging guys but I'm letting you know
it's Jesus Michael with the fights to
this talkin what the [ __ ] I'm just
saying they're trying to steer us around
the clock here oh dude I mean it's good
stuff I didn't know that trust me oh
just get a bidet it's fine
I'm deal with that I tried that but hey
you try that you shoot it up the hoop
it's all good to go here yeah just get
the $10,000 that he owes that's not
tendon so you can get him for now like a
thousand bucks oh that's what you guys
want to buy you guys each one I've heard
they love that yeah considering under
your consider your [ __ ] was clean
from me consider me your Indian stole
[Laughter]
that's still tripping me out dude
are you sure anyway beyond the let's get
past this I went from New Delhi to New
Balance tall boys from New Delhi did you
fly Emirates yeah first yeah it's the
best isn't it yeah close that door and
you go to sleep did you put the pajamas
on no I do every time let me tell you I
get on that plane I go in that bathroom
I get buck-ass naked
i freeball the whole flight ooh oh it's
good that's when you have just a whole
suite you have the sweet the door closes
that's all you're good to go
flatbed nice pillow nice blanket they
put a little a little like a pad on the
on the chair so you go live oh it's good
[ __ ] oh yeah you take a shower on the
plane yes it's great [ __ ] right and you
know the shower on the plane this is a
commercial private first class on
Emirates oh you booked your shower time
you get five minutes and if there's
nobody else taking a shower with them
and you tell them they'll give you
another five Chuck we got to do that
yeah it's great and it's nice it's it's
wonderful
nice nice life like economy class I
don't know what that is man Southwest
has something back in coach with the
peasants I don't know if you could ever
fly coach you're six foot how much six
six yeah you can flying coach is brutal
no you can't sit in coach at six my
knees are in my chest yeah I don't even
know why you even attempt it that sucks
yeah and that's when first class wasn't
even good back then yeah yeah yeah and
now it's good he'd have to go Singapore
Airlines because of the wide ass seats
on Singapore Airlines are actually
uncomfortable for a long flight really
yeah cuz they're too wide there's no
where you have to pick a side we lean on
yeah I mean literally like you and I
could both sit in that chair together
well that's that could be nice for a
minute you know great experience for me
how did you go for today how were the
fights great yeah what sauce was there
any indian cats fighting and who won yes
that's right oh yeah yeah yeah we hit it
right on the dot pardon the pun as you
get to the hotel right in the in the lay
around your neck
everything like Hawaii yeah yeah yeah
and then some sweet yeah they give
something sweet to eat when you walk in
what hotel were you at the Taj Lands End
that's the one I usually stay that's my
[ __ ] good nice oh yeah yeah you go to a
five-star hotel in India it's another
world oh yeah her in the room
ah Mike's already had that I stayed at
the Taj myself
yeah I landed city yeah the Trump Taj if
you're in New York I stay at that chat
wall that's a good hotel
where's one fell cross street from my
friend's place yeah yeah it's great
looking rooms are soundproof so you
don't it's right in time screen you
don't hear a single sound in your room
that's and I got the Japanese toilets
two wins
yeah two wins clean [ __ ] and no noise
hey two good things you need that a
soundproof room where in my house yeah
what you girl at all
whoa scream above ha ha
no I don't know I can't you know what it
is I need somebody to guide me through
it to get on you to the place I need to
be yet I like a drunk high so what can
get me in that zone okay so you need
maybe something with a little more CBD
oh you know what I just had that for the
first time the other night the oil yeah
I can't sleep early and Pete has that
yummy some I love that you know put it
on my tongue and well Pete's all into
the plant medicines yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah at a good talk with him about that
that's awesome Chuck cbhi right I tried
that and I slept slept through the night
I'm not sleeping I'm Loco yawa you are
at least I didn't want to have to have
tonight that's good so felt better next
day yeah
he relaxed you yeah Alessia it does
relax you it's great for stress relief
great for anxiety great for sleep
because I put my head down but my mind
goes a thousand
miles an hour okay every night when you
sleep like three hours at least at the
most emotion really most yeah never
meditate no no your training is your
meditation but yeah I'm uh let's get to
much any of you somebody I don't sleep
up every hour and then three no three
hours I'm up and you also have breathing
thing right yeah yeah I got the
breathing thing too so sleep up you know
the broken nose [ __ ] uh-huh yeah well
glad I sleep apnea to stuff man you are
easy yeah though are usually good though
huh I do oh yeah I'm up I'm up a couple
times a night but uh you know for the
most part we'd really cannabis really
helps me sleep you know exercise is
great to help you sleep you guys all do
that yeah to meditation I wake up at
like once I wake up but I wake up like
to take a piss at like 6:00 and then I
might not back asleep till 7:30 oh yeah
and then I'm like chill just crank when
I don't go to sleep and then yeah I get
the pen when you're in the house you hit
you sleep good mic up all the time yeah
like that you know it's gonna go sleep
right now that people listening on this
[ __ ] podcast
wake up no way though hahaha no I mean
weed if you're interested Russ and I
also don't like the coughing part so
would I be better off for the pen yeah
or no not necessarily because some
people say you know vaping can give you
more of a coffin smoking really it's God
have you heard of this popcorn lung yeah
there's some good stuff out there but I
would say get yourself a tincture that
sounds like something illegal
a CB something eternal like what chucked
really it's an oil who do you rub it on
yeah no no it comes in an injectable
what a syringe but it's a thick thing
yeah they put on they put a little on
your finger and you're pulling him yeah
it's a long that's a ton yeah well it
tastes like tastes like you swallow a
joint that's it yeah how soon did it
work it takes about an hour so you gotta
take it you know uh now before you go
yeah for sure
all right you'll watch TV and before you
know what I was like shut the TV up
solid yep for you yeah for me yeah a lot
better than I did
yeah that's great I need to try that
thing you sure so it's a thick it's a
thick where can we make this marijuana
if I go yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean you
could get it from this great
establishment here I know I have tons of
it in the house
actually I came to rehab it's why I came
haha this morning my shoulder was
hurting
literally I was like [ __ ] I need that
roll-on from like you don't have oil no
we don't have the oil yet we're gonna
have it yeah yeah that's good yes yo
don't smoke like myself and you don't
smoke right now no you know they put the
oil maybe a little heroin but that's new
and that's not nothing
one day I went and had this big machine
gun coming out of the wall oh yeah yeah
with that didn't tear people from your
[ __ ] with you yeah that's what that
was my that was my intimidation Mike
came to the house and I put him on the
turntables oh I love that it's trying to
make Mike DJ he goes he was like yo I
always wanted to learn how to do this I
go I'll teach you if you want you'd love
it you know why Mike you could zoom out
and just [ __ ] play music [ __ ] you
became a celebrity DJ oh my god you'd be
making money at all get it
are you kidding me
Mike Tyson knocking out the hits this
weekend this weekend
that would be amazing
well add that to the Tyson entertainment
all right wonderful
yeah have might come DJ your birthday
now what I wanna give DJ's a good GJ for
the know here's what is the difference
now okay the good DJ doesn't get good
money
it's these [ __ ] artists that get the
[ __ ] big money okay well what do they
get the [ __ ] are [ __ ] our stuff
will get anywhere from a hundred
thousand a half a million a night and
like real real talented guys who know
how to [ __ ] DJ and rock a party and
change up the style or whatever they'll
be lucky if they get a thousand bucks
oh so if you don't know what you're
doing you get more yeah if you look good
and you know how to do [ __ ] jumping
jacks in front of a pair of CD players
yeah you're gonna make a lot of hops all
you got to get a record player what do
you know there's that kid marshmallow
head or whatever the [ __ ] is called I
don't know who's your favorite DJ I mean
I'm into real DJ so okay you're not
gonna know them but I mean jazzy jeff
was okay one of them he's ridiculously
talented so jazzy jeff deejay spin bed
starting from scratch [ __ ] there's so
many guys scratch bastard I knew Big Al
you can pick out I never knew big of a
lord finesse is one of my best friends
and lord finesse and big guy were like
you know they were they were in the same
crew we go the small guy yeah the small
dude yeah he was right he was dope the
[ __ ] he would say he was never [ __ ] your
mother should have swallowed you into me
stuff like that ass Beavis I get nothing
but head you know hey Mike you know I
asked you you used to have all that
dapper dan [ __ ] back in the day right
yeah and now he's designing for Gucci
like on the real yeah that's crazy
and his stuff is like kind of dope I got
a dapper dan Gucci t-shirt but it's hard
to find you got a but he's still making
stuff like you can go to him and ya
think it's tough you never want to go
back again some more Dan Ford and [ __ ]
I get you measured up I'll make a call
like someone annoying yeah but he tells
my dad Mike tell him how you got to hell
you are
cuz it wasn't like you could just walk
in and get it you had to like go to
three locations or some [ __ ] you have to
go on this I want together you go to the
shop they told me to go - you talk to
the African guy and gotta take your
measurements and everything right give
them the material that you want and they
say no you come back and make that it's
ready it was that fast yeah damn had it
hold up I remember seeing you with the
with the with link it was a MCM Jack and
MCM Tam so cool so cool that was at that
boudin's when you cracked the screen
yeah run into him was he Harlem guy
[ __ ] scream yeah oh so he was in his
hotel [ __ ] it sup guide today yeah you
know crazy though yeah who's mataji
green stuff Mike broke his hand hitting
him outside that for dead really yeah
yeah yeah Mike fought him to a 10-round
decision he couldn't talk about this guy
was not going anywhere and he kept
calling Mike Michele Tyson when he would
see him and like it was 50 brows wasn't
it
no it was a non-title that was not title
yeah it was like somewhere in between
James quick Tillis and how deep were you
when you rolled up when we saw you might
be dead that stain that's the dangerous
thing a street fight yeah I got into a
fight 92
I hit this kid he's coming at me with
just like I was on some like [ __ ]
and I that's kind of a punk anyway but I
threw a I threw a I feel right hand
first and he went back because he was
drunk
and when he was coming back up I
sidestep I hit him a left hook
but I hit him in the here you're started
bleeding like [ __ ] I killed it but it
was an earring that ripped off I thought
it was his earring i bleeding I was like
I don't know how I voided charge that
day he was a other DJ kid and then I
told my right go to the record saw set
you up I know the guy there so I got out
of it
well that was my payment back I got you
a discount at the record store you were
talking about Chuck almost choking this
dude out bodyguarding Liza Minnelli haha
Oh which it was at the SRV story SRV
notice who God had the camera when he
pulled the camera I thought he won't for
a gun you know so they gave the guy
first row tickets front row seats get
sued you still talk to Liza at all I
think what I I haven't seen her or
talked to her in a couple of years you
know she lives right here in Coldwater
Canyon in his valley oh that's cool
yeah so I went to go see her up there
been a while now been a long time I mean
I was widowed when I was 24 years old
yeah she was a long time ago Chuck yeah
literally 40 years ago 41 years ago
thank you very much here well every
moment I'm indium you can't give me a
problem expect me to ignore it what are
you 48 48 now yeah I quote your you seem
like birthday man Mike called me once
for my birthday and now I take this one
as another one will take that that's
really nice
I remember might call me for my birthday
I was like hey brother that's one wish
you happy birthday
look forwards again to know you better
in the future
peace and love brother and I said thanks
Mike call me and then if I sound like
you handed the phone back one [ __ ] was
that
I just say that haha what'd you do for
your birthday I did two shows in
Arlington Texas nice it was whatever was
you know yeah and then it was he happy
birthday Thea they did I'm not a big fan
of the song and uh when they tried to
bring out a cake because I'm gonna have
people that is a comedy show I don't to
make it [ __ ] weird yeah I just want
to make you laugh come on I want to
respect respect I took it as the respect
and I think that's good we got we did it
I was supposed to ride back that night
private and I got to the private Airport
and the [ __ ] plane had a leak in the
brake line they go we can't take off at
all well I go well you could take off
you just can't can't land this what the
problem is
take nos not this you're stopping when
we land is the issue
see you're stuck there no stuck there
thank God I didn't check out of the
hotel though I never check out I just
leave just in case some [ __ ] happens you
need to get back there sure yeah and you
kept the key of course there you go I
always leave the key me too there's no
going back for me auctioneering method I
keep it with me just in case
bah bah what do you like to smoke ab
weed yeah I know but what style um I
used to really like sativas those bring
you up right yeah those are the uppers
but uh you know lately some sativas have
been giving me making me a little too
anxious so I've been moving more towards
hybrids yeah there's the hybrid Tyson
stuff that I get and everybody seems to
really enjoy that one yeah it's a good
it's right in the middle the hybrid is
really nice yeah the T ranch hybrids is
a good one but I like you know I like to
just do CBD to you know D's on the
tongue yeah just keep that helps with my
anxiety that helps keep my pain level
low what do you have painless neck from
flack yeah
elbow hands hips it's your [ __ ] body
yeah say y'all body yeah I hope you're
too young to have all that [ __ ] wrong
with you I don't know right yes 31 30 30
30
my pants are [ __ ] 30 years old
I think we should wrap this up because
it's going nowhere at this point it's
just getting weird people I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this podcast although it's
getting there it's it's evolving yeah
you got you got four very distinct
personalities in here and Edmund seems
to be the smart guy in the group so
we're gonna let him do the driving
and and I'll talk the dumb [ __ ] and Mike
will chime in when he feels he it feels
this is necessary and it's necessary no
it's all Sabah's well I appreciate you
guys man it's great to hang out with you
I'm excited for this you really should
answer your mom's phone call
I mean she's calling right now while
we're on the air I can do better I just
wanna hear what your mom says to you
Abin you left the toilet unwashed your
mom's American yeah dad's American yeah
I'm the only non-american guy here
ya know that wall build thanks Mike yeah
we're awesome all right guys all right
this is s until next time
[Music]